.
BECAUSE RORY'S IN THE BACK
LOOKING FOR ZEBRAS.
>> HOUSEMAN RELATOR KEVIN
MCCARTHY JOINS US NOW.
KEVIN IN MY OVERSTATING IT?
ARE WE DONE WITH THE WOKE
MENTALITY?
>> I THINK THE COUNTRIES ON YOUR
VIEWERS CARESSES HER KNOW WE
HAVE A REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE GOING INTO JANUARY 3,
WE CAN TAKE IT EVEN FURTHER.
JUST THIS WEEK ANOTHER SUCCESS
WE HAD TO END THE VACCINE
MANDATE IN OUR MILITARY FOR THE
ARMY'S 15000 SHORT.
THE MARINES HAD TO LOWER THE
RECRUITMENT BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
GET THERE.
THEY KICKED 8000 MEN AND WOMEN
OUT.
YOU CAN WATCH WHAT'S GOING ON WE
HAVE A BATTLE STILL IN FRONT OF
US THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO UNITE
TOGETHER.
I FEEL THE TREND IS TURNING.
BRIAN: THE OTHER BIG STORY
VICTOR BUT IT IS A FREEMAN 55
YEARS OLD TO GO BACK AND BECOME
THE NUMBER ONE WEAPONS
TRAFFICKER IN THE WORLD THE MOST
DANGEROUS MEN OF THE WORLD AT
ONE POINT.
WE GOT BRITTNEY GRINER BACK FOR
THEIR ONCE HAPPY TO HAVE THE
BEST POSSIBLE PART OF THE WORLD
BACK BUT AT WHAT COST?
LOOK AT THE GUY WE GAVE IT BACK
TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> LET'S JUST WATCH THIS 60
MINUTES GUY.
>> TRAN ATE IN MY EYES IS ONE OF
THE MOST DANGEROUS MEN ON THE
FACE OF THE EARTH.
HE IS ARMING NOT ONLY DESIGNATED
TERRORIST GROUPS, INSURGENT
GROUPS HE IS ALSO ARMING VERY
POWERFUL DRUG TRAFFICKING CARTEL
AROUND THE GLOBE REGARDS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WALKED AWAY FROM
THIS DEAL FOR PAUL WHELAN.
HE DID THIS DEAL FOR BRITTNEY
GRINER.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> IS ONLY MAKES POOCH AND
STRONGER PER THIS MAKES EVERY
AMERICAN OVERSEAS NOW A TARGET.
YOU WATCH PUTIN COME OUT THE
NEXT DAY HE'S WILLING TO DO MORE
EXCHANGES, WHY?
YOU JUST TOOK THE MERCHANT OF
TERROR THE PERSON OUT TARGETING
AMERICAN MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
SERVICE.
FUNDING THE GUNS AND OTHERS TO
KILL PEOPLE FOR WNBA STAR THEY
GOT PICKED UP FOR MARIJUANA.
IT IS NOT EQUAL PART HARMS US.
IT WEAKENS US.
IT IS EXACT OF THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE GATES SAID ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
EVERY FOREIGN POLICY DECISION
HE'S MADE FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS HAS BEEN WRONGED.
THIS ONLY HARMS AMERICAN SPREAD
AT HARMS OUR COUNTRY.
EMPOWERS PUTIN AND THE TIME HE
IS AT WAR IN UKRAINE.
WHEN YOU THINK THE MERCHANT OF
TEARS GOING TO DO NEXT?
YOU THINK IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
BRING NEW WEAPONS UKRAINE TO
KILL MORE PEOPLE?
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HE IS
DOING.
EVEN BUT DEPARTMENT OFFENSE
WORRIES ABOUT IT.
>> OF A LOT OF PEOPLE IN YOUR
CORNER INCLUDING MIKE GALLAGHER
BUT HERE'S WHAT HE SAID EARLIER
ABOUT YOU.
>> I AM CONFIDENT KEVIN IS DOING
A REMARKABLE JOB IN TERMS OF
REACHING OUT TO MEMBERS WHO ARE
NOT COMMITTED TO VOTE FOR HIM AT
AN ASKING WHAT ARE YOUR CONCERNS
CUSTOMER QUICKLY MEET IN THE
MIDDLE TERMS OF RULES CHANGES?
THE FACT IS USING TO ELEVATE THE
ISSUE OF CHINA AND SUBSTANTIATE
A SELECT COMMITTEE ON CHINA
SOMETHING THE ENTIRE CONFERENCE
CAN GET BEHIND STREET IS GOING
TO PRIORITIZE THAT PRETTY IS
GOING TO PRIORITIZE FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT'S LONG OVERDUE IT'S FOR THE
MANY REASONS WHY I THINK HE
DESERVES TO BE SPEAKER.
>> ISAAC JIM JORDAN MANY PEOPLE
BROWBEAT MIKE GALLAGHER IS ON
BOARD.
HOW MANY MORE VOTES DO YOU NEED?
WHAT IS YOUR STRATEGY FOR
CONVERTING THEM?
>> JUST TALKING TO EVERYBODY BUT
THIS HAPPENS IN EVERY SPEAKER
RACE.
THE DIFFERENCE HERE IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS I'VE BEEN LEADER FOR
FOUR YEARS THOSE TWO ELECTION
CYCLES WE ONLY HAVE ONE SEATS
OUR GOAL WAS TO STOP THE BITING
AGENDA, TO WIN THE MAJORITY IN
FIRE NANCY PELOSI.
WE ACHIEVED ALL OF THOSE.
AT THE SAME TIME IF YOU WATCH
OTHER REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
THEY LOST, THE GOVERNOR'S LOSS,
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WIN.
WE ARE THE ONLY LINE OF DEFENSE.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS FIND A WAY
TO COME TOGETHER FOREVER PRIMARY
AFTER THE ELECTION AND I WENT
85% OF OPERA BELIEVE AT THE END
OF THE DAY WILL ALL FIND A PLACE
TO GET TOGETHER BECAUSE THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS IF WE DON'T.
NO SUBPOENAS GO OUT.
NO ABILITY TO USE THE POWER OF
THE PURSE TO STOP THE CSG AND
OTHERS.
NO ABILITY TO REPEAL 87000 IRS
AGENTS.
NO ABILITY TO REALLY MAKE THIS
ECONOMY AND MAKE US ENERGY
INDEPENDENT BIRD SO YES, WE WILL
FIND A PLACE TO GET THERE WE
WILL CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS UNTIL
WE DO.
>> SPIETH.
BRIAN: AND FUTURE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE WE SAW COMING OUT OF
TWITTER IS ELON MUSK UNMASKS
WHAT'S COMING OUT FROM THERE.
SO FOR YOU PERSONALLY YOU HAVE
ANOTHER MOVE YOU WANT TO MAKE
HER NOT ONLY HEAR FROM THE
FORMER EXECUTIVES MISSES
EGREGIOUS WHAT YOU'RE FIGHTING
THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE SECTION
2:30.
WHAT DID FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE DO
AS WELL THEY BECAME AN ARM OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE ARM OF
GOVERNMENT.
THOSE 51 INTEL AGENTS ASSIGN A
LETTER THAT SAID HUNTER BIDEN
INFORMATION WAS RESTAURANT
COLLISION.
I'M GOING TO HAVE A HEARING THAT
KLAPPER A BRANDON THAT AMERICA
WAS ABLE TO GIVE TO YOU MORE
INFORMATION BUT USE IT FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSE AND ALLY TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IT'S EXACTLY
ADAM SCHIFF HAS DONE TO US AND
THIS IS GOT